we begin this morning with the southeast
bracing for more severe weather powerful
winds and possible tornadoes from
tropical storm Esther battered parts of
Central and Eastern Florida overnight
creating potentially dangerous storm
surge along the Florida Panhandle right
now more than 10,000 customers have no
power nestor did weaken overnight but
it's still packing sustained winds of 50
miles an hour and could make landfall
this morning it is putting communities
still rebuilding after hurricane Michael
last year on edge as they prepared for
more powerful weather Hilary Lane is in
shell Point Beach in low-lying
Crawfordville this morning that's about
20 miles south of Tallahassee Hillary
good morning good morning in Florida's
panhandle the winds topped out at 50
miles per hour overnight and this
morning the wind is still gusting in the
rain just starting to pick up the
beaches here are eerily quiet as the
waves crash onto the shore
dramatic cell phone video captures
powerful winds lifting a semi-truck and
throwing it onto a moving SUV witnesses
say it was a tornado that turned the
tractor-trailer onto its side
neither of the drivers suffered injuries
the incident occurred overnight after
the National Weather Service issued a
tornado warning for parts of inland and
coastal Florida another driver on the
same highway recorded large chunks of
hail striking their windshield it just
sounded like a big old train coming in
residents in a Seminole mobile home park
reported damage to their homes and
downed power lines Pinellas County
firefighters say a roof caved as a
result of powerful winds from a possible
tornado we jumped in the tub and just as
we did the carport came off and hit the
pole behind my house in Panama City
residents are weary after hurricane
Michael decimated 75 percent of the city
one year ago anything that's associated
with the word storm for Mexico Beach you
know it's fresh on our minds Mexico
Beach mayor el Kathy says the rebuilding
process after Michael has left parts of
the city vulnerable to large storms you
can't have 75 percent of your city
destroyed by a hurricane and a year
later think that any disturbance in the
Gulf is not concerning Cali Holloman a
Lyman Wilson lost their home during
Michael when a tree fell through their
roof they've since moved their family of
nine into a FEMA trailer further inland
I'm more nervous than I was last time I
say that
and the National Weather Service is
trying to determine whether it was heavy
winds or a tornado that caused the
damage and while nestor has lost steam
overnight residents here along the coast
are on guard as the wind gusts and the
rain continues to fall Dana Hillary
thank you